hoy a 58 días de gobierno yo bailén
logra su meta de administrar 100
millones de vacunas en sus primeros 100
días una meta que aunque el mandatario
dijo que era ambiciosa las cifras
indican que iba en curso con las
proyecciones teniendo en cuenta que
incluso desde que se posicionó ya se
estaban administrando un millón de
vacunas diarias en eeuu de hecho el
promedio de vacunación en este país es
de 2,5 millones de vacunas al día así
las cosas el objetivo de que cada adulto
estadounidense tenga una vacuna
disponible antes del primero de mayo
como la anunció el propio bailén es muy
probable y así se llegaría a la
inmunidad de rebaño que se obtiene con
al menos un 70% de la población vacunada
si otras variantes del virus no terminan
siendo resistentes a las vacunas